deep beneath the quaint village of  cecilton evil was brewing  an infection one that could turn their  host into a feared mind flair  a being of immense psychic power  [Music]  you are adventurous you've accumulated  so much knowledge between each one of  you  we've been following the source of this  mind player hive we need to go deeper i  have a bad feeling about this  i was wondering when you would make it  here  within this hive there are thousands of  years of knowledge in this hive oh  someone in that group of yours is hiding  secrets for you to sit here and judge me  and to blame me is very weak of you  that's not how this game works the only  reason that anyone is still standing is  because of us we won't survive unless  we're together  we have to bring your hp to zero this is  the most important dice roll of your  entire life you better do it  [Music]  [Music]  hello hello everyone welcome i'm lehman  and welcome to my leisurely lair